TO AS A HEAD OF THE FALL
ELECTION.
MIKE EMANUEL HAS THE STORY.
>> WITH CONFLICTING POLLS OUT
THERE, HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADERS
AND THEIR MAJOR SUPPORTERS ARE
NOT TAKING ANY CHANCES AHEAD OF
NOVEMBER'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
SHELDON ABELSON HAS GIVEN
$30 MILLION TO HELP THE HOUSE
G.O.P. KEEP ITS MAJORITY.
IN HOUSE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
NANCY PELOSI MAY HAVE GIVEN
REPUBLICANS ANOTHER GIFT BY
SUGGESTING THAT SHE'D INCREASED
TAXES.
>> THE SECOND PART IS ACCURATE.
[LAUGHS]
I DO THINK THAT WE SHOULD
REVISIT THE TAX LEGISLATION AND
THE WAY THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE.
IN A BIPARTISAN, TRANSPARENT
WAY.
THAT THE RESULT IS UNIFYING FOR
THE COUNTRY.
>> CAMPAIGN OPERATIVES PLAN TO
PLAY THAT CLIP UNTIL ELECTION
DAY NOVEMBER AND SUGGEST THAT IT
MIGHT BE THE SHOT IN THE ARM
NEEDED TO ENERGIZE THE G.O.P.
BASE.
>> IS THAT ENOUGH TO ALARM
REPUBLICAN VOTERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY?
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES ON
HARDWORKING AMERICANS AND
BUSINESSES, THEY WANT TO MAKE IT
TO STAY IN AMERICA, I CANNOT
IMAGINE THAT AMERICA WILL WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> HOUSE REPUBLICANS WHIP STEVE
SCHOOLEY SAYS THAT THEY CAN RUN
ON THE RECORD.
>> THE LAST THING PEOPLE WANT TO
DO IS TURN THE CLOCK BACK AND GO
BACK-TO-BACK WHEN NANCY PELOSI
WAS SPEAKER AND RUNNING THROUGH
LEGISLATION THAT WRECKED THE
ECONOMY.
>> THE CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE TOLD
FOX HIS SIDE IS READY FOR A
BATTLE.
>> WE WILL STAND BY THE
CANDIDATES AND THE POLLING, I
NEVER SAID THAT THIS WILL BE
EASY.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGHT
FOR EVERY ENTRY KNOW THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE IN A POSITION TO DO
SO.
>> AS PART OF TRYING TO WIN THE
RACES, DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING FOR
NEW LEADERSHIP AND SAY THAT THEY